背後にず初めてそうです
怒ってます怒ってますあのここ最近で一番腹買ったという変わりそれはないでしょって
いう感じのことがあったんであのよかったら口動画たと思って聴いてください
結構ブツ切れましたねあのこの動画は別に何だろうこれした人を同行したいとかこれし
た一音陥れた
a とかそういうわけじゃなくてちょっと俺の本の色々話したくて話してるだけです
なぜ別にこれをした人を同行したきっかけでもないし
心当たりある人がもしいたらこういうことを考えてやめてほしいなっていう感じの動画
です良かったら見てください
めちゃ進めなく座るいい感じなんですけども
視聴者さんっていうかファーブなのかどうかもわかんないですけど
視聴者さんからちょっと
女ザクちゃーん
力ないよええという人がいたんで一応ドイツおきたかって言うんですね
これが東京にお仕事行ってその帰りたい車であの人との接触を避けるためには東京に
汚職というとき全部車で移動するんですけどとだけど帰りの法則道路で寄ったサービス
エリアで起きた事の話ですあの
再現 vtr 作ったんでぜひご覧ください結構正確に作ってあると
いますどうぞ
これは肇社長が東京の仕事も多い
静岡へ帰っている途中の道のサービスエリアの話である
あれ+ねえかれたなぁ
バットに牛どう売ってるっているあもう
繰りましょうあね何柔軟性も遅いしなんて音程
やがった東にくれて会やお箸た方これ官は太るかね本当に
始めるぞああほんと肇社長が新レーダー
本当はすごい
肇社長ですよねいつも見てます
はいんマジじゃんっすげええええ
写真撮ってもらっていいですか私もいいですかああああ
アサシン
言いませんちょっと今ものコールドとかもあるんであんまり使うれないですよ今日は
写真全部あのお断りしてるんで気もちょっとください
えええええええ
ダメだってダメねえおのような一枚第一番におねがいおねがい曽根一応的に市場でこと
団地にそれだけごめんなさいちょっと他の人も断ってるんですよねん
ああそうなんですねそう言いません
[音楽]
すみません
阿部さああいつらは盗撮してますね
[音楽]
はいどうだったでしょうか
どう思います俺はめちゃくちゃ腹たちましたけどね
一応証人もいますじゃああーいやー困りましたね本当にあらゆる線きて許せ
100を得ずでまぁの写真断ったことは悪いですそしてことで僕はレーサーの撮れば
よかったんですけどもソーシャル destin ってみんな距離明けでサーマ少しで
さあ頑張ってた自粛としてさあ感染予防のためにみんな頑張ってるのにそういう状況に
よくそんな近距離に近寄れるだって言ってかも帰って間も床に感染症予防のため距離を
開けてください
って書いてんのにどうぞまふくぜん近づいてくださのステーシ
俺じゃなかったら多分怒られてますよって俺はザそんな関連してるかとか分からない
そうやってもカーフェンしてるかどうかわかんないその距離で詰められても困るし
女篇の状況だけ結構気づかれてないですよ周りの人も外しちゃちゃーん発をザって何か
写真撮れたら取るような空気もちょっとあったんで
ここでコーヒーと頑張って集まってもダメだしもう僕は写真撮るべきじゃないなんて
判断してすぐそういう反応下したんですけど断った後の態度な
その下はなんや終えしたを終えのもんね待ったんだぞ
行っキーでよく居るけどそういう人なんかしただして起こりがちな人いるけど普通に
気持ちいいんだよってくださいうわーマジかーとが落ち込まれたりする食べてるんです
けどを頃
れるのはすごいなと思って
いいいいね全てに百歩譲って規模にされなかったのはこちらのサービス精神が低かった
ということで別にいいんですけど別にいいけどは俺は育ったのこと性格悪いなと思い
ますけどね全然いいですけど全然いいですけどありがとうございます凄い嬉しいです
嬉しいですけど起こるかなって感じでございましたまーさんで最後決まりのねあの
帰り際の盗撮もカメラを聞こえてるしかねない
らしいわかるからねなんかもは同3でをとってたんですよそれもその女性のほうもなん
でさっきまでごめんなさいといったんで急に距離離れた瞬間その逮捕
すごいよ演技力すごいね徐々になった方がいいんじゃない
ちょっとめちゃくちゃ目なくそんな話が最近起きました
すっきりしたすっきりしたちょっと後面接の俺もねあるその理不尽なことかさっきパパ
なかったことも導入しようと決めてるんで今後さらにこういう口動画出させてください
状況が状況でまだ収まっておりませんこれが生んだりマスクをしているのか何のために
人は距離を開けて列に並ぶのか想像もなんでサービス言ったかっていうとそもそもご飯
食べるタイミングがなくてか
入ってから12時前に食べたいねっていう感じでぎゅうどんだけちょっと張ってすぐ
帰ろうと思ってるんですけどそこでの出来事ですねそのまま弓道も食べれずに書い
たっていう話なんですけど
うーん操作ルディスターサン守りましょうマスク白さすがにマスクは白
何のためにみんな頑張ってるかね
[音楽]
ブーブー
いっ
[音楽]